round three of the 2016 sinquefield cup  here in st. Louis it was the most  dynamic round of the tournament so far  as the world's top players did battle in  some sort and exciting positions  tournament co-leader Vasily topalov  inexplicably blundered upon to world  number two max in vashi lagrave for the  former world champion put up a staunch  defense and managed to hold a draw  five-time world champion Viswanathan  Anand s8 a few original ideas against  Hikaru Nakamura but the American star  found all the right moves to draw the  game and stay within a stone's throw of  the leaders defending champion Levon  Aronian wheeled out an enterprising  novelty against grandchester leader  Wesley so but after the fireworks had  ended the players had kept the peace and  their position atop the standings with a  jumbled leaderboard who will make a push  to separate themselves from the rest of  the field round four coming up next